freunde es ist wieder soweit ein tag als
persönlicher koch heute mit sandra es
wird heute früh die lte sandwiches geben
was das ist erkläre ich euch gleich okay
wir sind angekommen weil sandra und ihr
selbst schon im hintergrund ich habe
bereits mit backofen vorgeheizt ich habe
ja gerade schon gesagt wir machen
die lts sandwiches blt das steht für
bacon levels also salat und tomaten
das klingt sehr einfach sind nur 34
anteil aber es ist das geilste was man
zum frühstück essen wird wird genauso
schlecht sagen wenn wir nach gemacht und
luca ja ich war so lecker
theoretisch muss sich niemand und mein
name ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass
wir wollen auf jeden fall noch die eine
oder andere leckere sachen machen heute
das ist wirklich super sind wir also
diese drei zutaten gibt es um und ganz
wichtig mayonnaise aber ansonsten ist ja
nichts drauf und schmeckt so lecker das
heißt wir warten kurs ist der backofen
halten zeigt ihr euch nichts
weitergegangen hätte einfach mal den
bacon auf einem stück backpapier
normalerweise macht man es auf einem
backblech wir können hier heute aber
leider nur mit einem rucksack ein
backblech also halb so wild also ich
dass meine küche so kannst du viel zu
übertrieben sieht aber echt verse aus
also edelstein
es ist ziemlich gut ja man hat eben
schon hinter der kamera gesagt wieso zu
kochen schwere erzähl mal da eigentlich
mache ich nudeln oder dokumente zu hauf
ich habe da keine talent und ich
frühstücke eigentlich nie da ist kann
die halle liegt ist es ein stück brot
die wir in der scheiße drauf oder fast
überhaupt nicht länger also du lässt es
dann einfach auch ja ich hatte es auch
eine ganze
also dann habe ich mir frühstück gemacht
und mir wurde dann einfach nicht
schlecht jedes mal solche sind
ausbreiten können jetzt gleich in den
backofen vorgeheizt reinhauen und dann
wird es super körnchen christian jetzt
nicht mehr der fall
ja wir meinen im ofen weil dann wird der
christian fröhlich nrw zu machen und
schneiden die ihm richtig feine scheiben
das ist wichtig dass sie kein sieg weil
wir werden die tomaten pfeffern und
salzen und das krasse ist bei tomaten
wenn man die seite die entwickeln an so
einem geisteskranken geschmack unseren
geisteskranker euro macht eigentlich
tomate nicht mehr rütteln
keiner weiß oder ist man alles eingelegt
eigentlich die übelste art und so
eingelegt tomatensorten scalzo wir gehen
wir schon den bacon in den backofen rein
tue ich heute auch noch irgendwas dass
wir fünf sechs minuten da drin in der
zeit bereich den salat vor
ich werde einfach 13 fit machen für mich
sagen wir uns das besser wissen zur
seite
harald f glück gehabt
er ist deutscher und jetzt das ist
nämlich geheimnis kommt die
toastscheiben oben und zwar auf das fett
was der welten ausgelassen hat und
dadurch werden die anderen level kramm
china und japan hinzu und gleich ist es
soweit
[Musik]
wir wohnen jetzt die toastscheiben hier
raus unangetastet ich habe dir einmal
gesendet damit auch den beiden seiten
ein bisschen öl drankommt es ist auf
jeden fall deutlich besser so ist man
die dinge richtig 1000 weil das ganze
team von bacon dabei ist natürlich nicht
das gesündeste frühstück treffen sie
auch verdampft egal ob es gesund ist
oder nicht so lecker ok und jetzt was
macht das ganze noch weniger gesund
kommt mein leben aber nicht einreden
möglich ist es wirklich bei diesem
frühstück dass man ordentlich meine
these drauf hat kann es mit elan führung
geschmack war noch nicht vor ort
du wirst es liegen die chance echt nicht
vorstellen kann man schon vorstellen
nachdem dies nicht einst helmut rezept
in grüner kölner innenstadt feuer das
war geil wie macht man selber sagt der
sohn
vielleicht leute irgendwann mal weiter
persönlicher topos abnehmen köln
wir nehmen uns protoss drei steilen weg
nach sind noch zwei übrig das herz die
zwei privat so jetzt ganz wichtig fed
tomaten überall drauf so richtig
gesteckt deshalb haben wir sie so schön
flach geschnitten damit er ordentlich
was drauf geht also ist das beste was
der welt je passiert ist gewisse
ungeduld
und ganz wichtig ein richtiges szenische
wahrscheinlich wird es durch schläge an
seinen dauert und in der mitte
zerschnitten seien nicht so schaffen
glaube das könnte das problem werden die
metzger spricht es einfach komplett
warum vielleicht damit deshalb ein
bisschen schief mitten im sommer beim
frühstück für den heutigen tagen muss
ich das auch gleich rating von 110 ganz
genau das sollen die agenten zu sagen
das geht nämlich genau darum
gewiss es ist perfekt gesalzen geil
das freut mich es 18 prozent eigentlich
darf zuerst auf das wissen und die
region betrifft ich würde sagen wir es
erst mal ruhe auf und dann kommen wir
zum endgültigen rating sowie haben auch
gegessen wir sehen unsere karten
komplett leerer dann würdest du deine
beim rating noch mal bestätigen erst
jetzt zu vollziehen ist wichtig auch
durch nützlich ist ganz gespannt wird
zum mittagessen schnitzen geben wir
fangen jetzt an das war nämlich anfang
ein paar kartoffeln zu schälen
rockig mal weiter dann schneide ich das
ganze entwürfe und gebt es kochen dabei
vergessen sind die geschnittenen
kartoffeln kocht das wasser und geheime
zutat habe ich von meinem lieblings koch
youtuber kenji lopez man muss ein
bisschen backpulver rein machen weil die
dadurch viel kräftiger werden
auch wenn die neu in die kochende zu
ungefähr der zwischenzeit habe ich hier
schon vorbereitet ein bisschen rosmarin
und 2 knoblauchzehen am besten so eine
unbeschichtete weil wir wollen rest
bekommen tiergerecht ein bisschen
olivenöl hinein und ordentlich was sein
das wird jetzt relativ schnell sehr heiß
werden der zwischenzeitlich machen
rosmarin hier mal ein bisschen klein den
gehen jetzt direkt in die pfanne wird
relativ schnell heißt sein und zudem
große marin kommen noch zwei gepresste
zehen knoblauch
der knoblauch leicht gelb golden wird
dann werden wir das ganze abschütten die
ganzen kräuter und so sollen eben nicht
mit rein in den ofen nur das öl kommt
eben wieder an die kartoffel und der
rest wird erstmal dafür gibt es ein
cooles kopf worten wenn sie braucht
so und wir führen jetzt eben dieses öl
hier aber nur das dementsprechend sollte
ganz so dass drinbleiben benutze ich
dieses ding was überhaupt nicht dafür
gemacht ist was man daran erkennen dass
ein bisschen was mit rauskommt aber ist
es okay ist besser als wenn alles gut
läuft könnten wir dieses rosmarin
knoblauch und hierdurch die rechtlichen
kräutersalat hat ihren schon ungeklärt
das heißt wir müssen jetzt gas geben
dürfen kommt vom herd unter das ab jetzt
gehen wir das öl in diese große schüssel
hinein
aber auch die kartoffel nicht erst mal
schaffen sich das alles gut verbindet
und die kartoffeln sind außen wie so ein
kartoffelbrei bekommen ihr seht das
schon funktioniert hier ein bisschen die
kraft offen hier in den ofen hinein
ganz ohne backpapier oder sonst einfach
das einzige was man beachten dass sie
halt ein bisschen abstand voneinander
und die bleiben gleich 20 minuten
währenddessen kümmert mich das schon ist
der schwimmverein 230 grad der übrigens
bestens sehen können und jetzt so sein
heißt ist dann auch angekommen
wir sind schon ein bisschen am snacken
weil der hunger langsam kippt aber ich
beeile mich wir müssen jetzt einen
pannierstraße machen uns ja klar das
geht jetzt hier das mittel habe hier ein
top vorbereitet in den gebe ich ein
bisschen schweineschmalz und pflanzen
fest ok unsere pannierstraße steht wir
haben hier einmal doppel griffiges mail
drei stück einfach richtig fein gespielt
und semmelbrösel diese stationen
durchläuft gleich jedes schnitt aber
bevor wir das tun müssen wir das ganze
erst mal anklopfen und das wollte ich
schon immer tun wollte zum ersten
schnitts ich bin sehr gespannt ob ich
das hinkriege und wie es funktioniert
gibt zwei seiten einmal eine mit punkten
und einmal eine so man muss auf jeden
fall aufpassen dass das schnitzel nicht
richtig wird und gar nicht mal an
man merkt sich das größer wird direkt
faszinieren
[Musik]
aber für meine gäste immer alles so nett
mexiko ist sollte so groß werden aber es
wird nicht in meinen kopf passen das
heißt ich werde benannt durch jetzt
bringt auch schon der straße an das ist
so cool
so müssen natürlich sauber ich werde das
ganze jetzt mal hier ein bisschen an
feuchten dann legen wir das in die erste
station deswegen das jetzt einmal
gegenüber
auch von beiden seiten da ist dann gut
abtropfen dann kommt in die semmelbrösel
hinein sagt man wird halt richtig krank
genève an denselben und schnitzel wird
ja gut da durch das ist quatsch ist
nochmal ein lieblingswort nummer zwei
ist jetzt quasi was läuft ich muss euch
dessen detail zeigen alles da wir die
ersten schnitzel fertig und ich denke
mal ich mache immer zwei auf einmal
hinein und jetzt muss man das schnitzel
und weit dass zum 30
dabei hat konstant in bewegung halten
weil dadurch die spitze ich hätte
niemals gedacht dass ich selbst mal wenn
ich bin richtig happy das vorgeschlagen
hat
[Musik]
ich glaube demnächst glaube ich ganz
viele leute einfach schnitzel wurde
geehrt so glücklich
dieses essen macht man sowas mal mutter
ist jetzt einfach noch lose ich hab es
muss laut max ja alles richtig krank sie
seien deswegen machen wir das alles so
klar wie möglich ist der erste gast der
auch mit anpackt hier macht er jetzt
sogar das geschrieben hast du nächster
was auch immer doch maxime wollten nicht
dass alles extrakt letzten beiden
schnitzel sind jetzt auch fertig
das wollen wir auch geben die hier
wieder dass ich bin profi
das macht man so wie gerade am anfang
schon erwähnt um die kräuter wieder
hinein s und der roadster sehen diese
familie ist eigentlich mein großer flex
in der küche jetzt nehme ich meine mama
mal geschenkt und das ist eine designer
pfeffermühle weil ich meine ich weiß
wirklich nicht was ich mir zum
geburtstag wünschen könnte aber eine
familie will irgendwie kugel der nacht
hat die seinen persönlichen traum
ich bin sehr gespannt was mir gleich ein
rating geben wirst du mir sagen wir das
betriebs haben nach den ice kathrin
keller ist auch zu dessen ist wieder
zeit für das rating hast du dann 10 15
ich kann ja nicht jedes mal sauer was
ist so gläser wirklich richtig lecker
max ich hab ich ja gesagt dass ich zum
allerersten mal gemacht haben ich hätte
selbst wirklich nicht gedacht dass es so
lecker wird also bin ich wirklich sehr
zufrieden über diese note und probiere
wird schwer aber beim abendessen auch
noch mal die zehn von zehn rauszuhauen
würde sagen wir sehen uns da sind wir
wieder beim abendessen sandra sie farbe
für das abend ist ja ich habe hier heute
treiben gezogen
die maschine auch nicht in einem tag
merkt ihr was ich hatte die ganze zeit
eine peinlichkeit gemachten smash bürger
wie das klappt habe ich euch ja
eigentlich um eine einzelne video
gezeigt deshalb habe ich schon mal alles
vorbereitet und hat mich kurz ich habe
fleischbällchen vorbereitet ich habe
japans ansonsten braucht man ja quasi
nur brötchen ketchup mayo aber ich
dachte mir weil wir den ganzen tag
einfach nur scheiße wir kleinen salat
vielleicht würde dafür eine kurze diese
salat und dass dieser anschlag geplant
ist
da waren wir wieder bei du hast alle
gadgets ja stimmt dann erstaunt die
ganze zeit über die auswertung meiner
küche wirklich alles selbst zum grill
jedes passt das zeug dazu jetzt sogar
betreten rhetorik fritteuse der ecke
ständer es nicht normal für einen wie
ein bis macht ich bin 23 23 jährigen
typen achtjähriger bub vermisst
nein er ist küchen wer ist das habe ich
nicht geliefert bekommen größte schande
ansage an heide kommt bei heimischen
salado omas klamotten kaufen die haben
richtig gutes angebot für eine
kitchenette sich bestellten dem einfach
nicht geliefert sie einstudiert als auch
ansage kommt also jetzt noch schnell die
tomaten vierteln belastet das dressing
ich liebe leute deshalb verteilen wir
das ist jetzt ein bisschen darüber
und jetzt der gute alte dave trick des
fertigen lenken
jetzt würde ich sagen gibt es an die
bürger der griechischen flimmern draußen
[Musik]
gefunden
ja das ist gute bei den bürgern und da
ist ein abendessen das ging schnell
[Musik]
das war das letzte essen ich bin
gespannt auf deine bewertung wie ich
kann jetzt wurden 130 das echt krass ich
hatte in der ersten folge mit jan vom
gewitter im kopf auf 31 43 war ein
bisschen kritischer wer weiß wie es in
der nächsten folge aussieht dank auf
jeden fall dass ich wieder zugeschaut
haben wir sehen dieses video wieder